*Jumpscare*
WOAHH FFFFUCK YoU!
Hello everybody My name is Markiplier.
and welcome to Whiskers.
Now it may look like it on it's surface
but I do not believe
this is a five nights at freddy's fan game.
This game actually came out before five nights at freddy's, if i'm not mistaken
But either way it's .. only like.. it's its own thing as far as I know
Uhh..
What this is, is a point-and-click adventure horror game.
Uhh
that takes...
bruuah?
...place somewhere
Oooo
Hi! Hello? Are you whiskers?
I think you might be Whiskers
(Mark: Yes.)
(Mark: Very Good)
Well, why did you wake me up then?
W-Wai- hey no! Ey! Woah! Don't do the-
You're doing the villain lean on the way out. It's very creepy. Why'd you do that?
Okay, why am I here? Why did you wake me up and then tell me to rest?
Doesn't make any sense
I'll take this-- Awww, too high..
Lemme move the chair *Mark mumbling* I know.. uh..
Clunk.
Let's see...
...plunk-AHhohoho
Me am big smart in my brain hole
uahh..oh...hey..
Me'am know answer to this puzzle, but me'am may not like what's in the darkness when I...
*click* (Nothing...)
Oh, ok good. It doesn't work.
Ok, well.. There is definitely a...
Woah, there's something movin-- WAIT A MINUTE
Wait, do you see that?
There's something moving in the darkness
Right there. Do you see that?
Hooohhh...
You thought I wouldn't notice you HAH? Oh.......
I'm all...
...Over you
Okay
So I need
Some kind of form of light or something how am I gonna be able to?
Get in there if I can't..*sighs*  I can't move that again. Doors locked tight. Okay, there's something in there
I know-- I see you moving there
*Jumpscare* (Wild Bunny Appeared)
WOOAH
FuCK YoU...
*silence*
Sack of shit. Bag of ass....
...Dude!
Hi. Nice..
..Hat >:(
Unless that's your head, then I'm sorry *Hapufft*. I apologize.
Okay. Alright then, I'm just gonna...
Nothing, I can take off you? Okay, Alright, I'll be on my way.
*Mark reading* HE IS HIDING?
Great! :D Let him stay hiding!
Thanks for the heads up. Imma gonna go upstairs. Good god!
Alright
THUNK! LET ME N-MAKE SOME NOISE!
HOPE NO WHISKER MAN COMES TO GET ME
Right. thUNK. THUNK!
You're not trying to be stealthy about escaping MY PRISON CELL!
ANYWAY, HERE I GO
I cant lift that door with my butthole
All right, so nothing in there; but useless junk. Okay
Well, can I take that th-that saw looks the opposite of useless
that saw use--lo-looks useFUL
Looks like full of use
Ooo
*Reading* That's odd. There is no dust only on that cover...
*Mockingly*  Well let me open it.  How about I do that?
*still mocking* Tha-that seems like the yes thing to do
Alright, whatever. Okay, so
Is there like some tooool that I neeeed?
Agh
Ah, guys'z super cold..
Hang on, one second.. *Markiplier noises*
By the way, uh...
Brand-new Christmas sweaters on sale now; Markiplier.com
Link's in the description. That wasn't a planned promo (Or was it?)
It is legitimately cold and these are cozy so *laughs* Imma do that
Also I've got fleece blankets..
It's blanket on sale. It's got- It's got-It's blanket.
Blanket-y
Got a logo on it. It's pretty cool. There.
There...th-there
There It is. There it is.
Like a Matador cape 'cause cold
I don't know why, like, this office, like usually I have offices that get hot
So I was like I definitely want an office that can stay cool
And it's fricken friged in here
Also I'm..
bundling up to hiiide
Alright. Okay.
Anybody got a scwewdwiver?
Please?
Okay
I can't lift that door with my bare hands
Wha...DAH I couldn't use any of this OBVIOUSLY useless junk here!
So I guess I'm just screwed
Is---...?? *Markiplier senses a disturbance in the force*
Do you guys hear?
.... Guys hear something?
Door's locked tight....mmkay...
*Mark rapidly clicking*
All right
What happened to that crowbar? (It broke man)
Alright, well, I'm screwed, aren't I?
God, there's gotta be like some kind of tool that I can get..
but can't seem to interact with anything else
SO
Do you have anything? You've got nothing?
You've just got a weird head.. Okay,
Alright, okay?
All right, okay?
*game thunking with mark's clicking*
*tink* *Mark gasps*
TTTTHHEERREEEE we go! Oookay!
Persistant pays the bill-ahhhhhh *He vanished!*
You didn't need to make that noise. I would have been spooked anyway
All right, well ..he's around? That's just how he sleeps apparently.
He's like a bat or something *game jingle*  Oh?
The boiler contains a small shiny door key
*stutter of confusion*
Why? ...Heh..
Why does it contain that? I'm curious honestly?
Where'd the- where did he go?
There was nowhere else for him really to go except, in my general direction so
*door opens* Aha?
I got bad feeling about that door
*Darkplier in action; Screams of his victims*
Hey, look...
All my suspicions were confirmed. This is the unhappy door...
Ahh, filled with nightmares
Okay.... ooo!
Can't hide from me. I know what I'm about-- okay, Apparently, I'm in this hole now.
I must be ...very small
Nobody make a joke about that...
*game thunking*  Mark: thunk, thunk. knock-knock!
Buh---Hi!
Scus---Haha!
Excuse- excuse- excuse me.. hahaha! Excuse me, Sir. Ma'am. Excuse- Excuse me
*Reading* Poor little fellow, starved to death.
Excuse me
Not safe, or is that?
Nothing
Totally safe. Nothing to fear.
Totally safe, my friend. That's what it says
There's nothing to fear totally safe my friend.
That's what the whole message is. That's what it is.
Alright. Thanks.
Thank you. Thank you
Thank you very much about that
I got a booone
.. because my first instinct if I'm trapped in a place and I find a skeleton is like
This looks useful!
Ho! I could thunk someone
real hard with this Blaunk-er.
..Okay. All right. Anyway, gotta go to the bathroom..
Mm. Death is here. Can't run. Mm, well, okay.
Muhaha... haha
What a fun bathroom! All right! Okay!
Who--
Who's gonna scare me first? Eeny meeny miny moe catch a tiger by the toe any hollers let him go?
Gonna flush a bone down a toilet (uncomfortable chuckle)
All right, see ya.
See you guys. I'm gonna go upstairs. Ooo very pre- oh okay. Whoa.. Nope. Not ready for that, okay.
What's in here?
Hello, ah! Is that the outline of whose bone this belongs to?
Okay, gotta
Excuse me,can I get that? *jingle* Thank you. Small safe key.. you want this? Thank you! Thank you so muuch!
Whoo I wonder where this goes! *reading* I hid the gun in the prison cell
*confused Markimoo*
You mean the prison cell I was just in?! Okay, hid a gun...
in the
Prison cell
So there's it
Wonk it! Oh, well, now nevermind- How about you screw it? (loud breaking noise)
Ohhhhhh. It's an old revolver with only one bullet left
Wonder when I'm gonna use that one
Hmm...
Got a gun. I'm ready for ya!
Uh...Urnh..
Alright *sniff*
Okay ..well now what? Why did I need a gun?
Why did I need a gun? I could use it as a very short-term source of light... if I shoot a bangy
Bang!
Then I'd see something, right? That's how it works
That's how it works.
Okay, whatever
so I need some source of light..
Maybe I could rig this bone up with some cloth..
and burn it. Like if I rig
if I rig my...
If I rig this bone up with these scraps of clothing from this mysterious dead body
Can I SHOOT anybody?
Anybody wanna get shot?
Maybe if I condense the methane from the poop still remaining in these toilets
Then I could possibly light a fire
Womp
Screwdriver! Gun on door! Nah, (sarcastically) I thought gun on door was gonna work for sure!
Well, I guess not
How about over here?
Can I blonk ya?
Are these boxes blonkable?
Can I shoot in this tube?
Aghhhh. I'm at a loss
Oo, scoochie..
Alright, and maybe I could blonk this chair for some firewood.
No? Alright, okay, alriiiiiiight, okaaaay (high pitch squealing)
Ah huh...
Well,
I am
lost.
Woah
Wait whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Where wh-wh? What happened?
Kay, another victim by the infamous Mr.Whiskers
Last Thursday night, Dutch salesman Alexander Wit has been taken from his home
Just as the previous kidnappings, a dead mouse and a blank note has been found at the crime scene
This is the 14th victim taken by Mr. Whiskers. A local witness was able to take a vague picture of Mr. Whiskers
Oh, thank you. What is that the Loch Ness monster? Is Mr. Whiskers a UFO?
What's going on here with this picture, huh?
Oh what, in this day and age
1988, they don't exactly have the technology with which to make a better picture?
I heard that. Also, I question the conundrum of leaving a dead mouse in a world where
cats and horses and stuff real life day
Is that like a full-grown like dead body to them? Is that like another person?
Like, oh god not only did he kidnap someone but
also a dead body, murder kidnapping! Okay anyway, I see. So that's interesting..
Uh huh, I still can't see shit down here
(loud bang) HEEEEeeeeeeeeeeeeey
I saw something (nervous laugh*
I say-- I think.. I think I saw something. I'm pretty sure I
Funcle' my thinky thunkle. Let me prep my gun
Ah. Toliet voice: "Go away, leave me be"
No, I got a gun
I don't wanna leave you be
Bang!
Ohhh.
Waaaait
Wait
Waaait a minute
Whaaaat?
You'll trade me a LIST that you don't know what is what.. for a gun.
Yeah blonk? You want a screwdriver maybe? If I tape this screwdriver to this bone, it'll look like a gun
Here ya go.
(Trigger warning incoming..)
Ohhhhhh (gun being cocked, gunshot) Bwaaaaaaaa, I didn't want that!
*Stunned markimoo*
Ahhhhhhhhhh!
(More Mark screaming)
Ahhhhhhh!
Okay
All right
Things to remember: saw two planks, use eight nails, board up five windows, keep one bullet in the gun
Oh my god.
Ugh
Geez
That's fucking awful. Well, I have that now-- wait. Oh! Two, eight, five, one.
For the code.. okay, why do I have a bone?
All right, whatever
Two
Eight
Mmmmmm, five
One, okay
Okay, ugh, I don't trust you.
I don't trust you.
OH HI Mr. Moo Moo!
I'm beginning to think that people don't actually
I'm beginning to think that people aren't actually anthropomorphic animals
and there just wearin-- no that's... what?
Is this just normal human bodies with animal heads? Is that what pe-people are in this world?
I don't understand
Whoa all right I got a flash-- ohhh that..
17 X 4 Y
Do I need to remember that?
17 X 4 Y!
Remember that, 17 X 4 Y.
I don't know why? 17 X 4 Y
17 to the right 4 down ohhh!
Thank you for explaining it to me
17 to the right 4 down
Anything else I need to know in here?
Seems like that mask is all sewed up
Ohhhhh
Ohhhhhh I get it! I get it. okay, alright, so..
Mr. Whiskers is doing some weirdness with tying masks to people's faces
17 to the right, 4 down. 17 to the right, 4 down. 17 to the right, 4 down
Click! Oh, nope. Don't like this. no. nope.
(barking)
*Poocher jumpscare* *Mark screams*  Oh hi
(barking continues) That is..uh.. ohh .. bone!
You want the bone?
You are--now that I know that you're just, ah--is that a bottle of piss?
Oh hi
ahwha..
Okay!
Alright!
I'm worried about this
*unsure markimoo noise*
Oo.. seems like a good spare tire..
Ah just sh- just like I'm trying to escape for my life, and I'm just like aa..
Thunk! thunk! This still got some air in it. I could probably sell this
probably could get like
50/ 60 bucks off of this bad boy. Alright! Okay, when I get out of here I'm gonna be starting off
with a bonus
It's a Jack. Seems to be an unusual good condition. Ah!
Unusual good, okay, so I need to fix up a car to get out of here.
That's the thing is the..
long and the short
So how long was that guy, the--the dog guy in the dark just down here?
Just waiting for me-- saw me come down each time, but only decided to bark once i had a flashlight
(mumbling) I see how it is..
All right, well, you have fun of that.
I will see you laterrr
What do I need to--oh I know what I need to Jack!
oo, I need to jack.. this door! ..Ah..
Good jackin'
Ooh
Bad grassin', okay, all right, okay? All right?
Oh ooo
"Find the watching"
Find-- Ku--uu- FIND A
Dictionary!
That's not the right word.
God,eh, My insult did not come across (?) so...
I dunno
"This gate is protected by electricity."
Oh! that--- I thought that was fireflies. That's electricity.
Okay, alright, whatever you say
Sure, all right. What's down here I wonder. I wonder
A drain, I wonder. I wonder.
Anything in the corner there?
Anything floating around here?
Hmm
All right!  "find the watching"
I don't know what 'the watching' is, but okay?
He is hiding
Is he watching?
I'm trying to find the watching.
It must have something to do with
four---17 to the right, four down
It's gotta of have something to do with that
Well,  heh, why did I just try to put a tire in the mirror? I'm a frickin' idiot
Oh god
I don't wanna break a leg. yeah, sure ok.
Is there any place here that I could have..
Done anything to do with a coordinate
*mumbling about 17 to the right, 4 down*
Wait! Oh, wait.
No. Here.
Ah
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven
eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve,
thirteen, fourteen, fifteen, sixteen, seventeen.
Four.
HEEEY
Oh, that's a terrible key. I don't like- I've regret picking that up
But I have that now okay, all right. Well.
I know what door this goes to magically and wonderfully. all right here we go!
*Beautiful string music*
Ah
The watching. That sick bastard is watching us for his-EEYY!
(The Watching talking)
Hi, hello.
the..
The Boar Man?
The BOAR man?
*electricity crackles*
Uh
Where's uh --where's the Boar Man?
wait, where's the Boar Man? Can I see where the Boar Man is?
Nope! I don't know where the Boar Man is.
Okay, well, I guess I'm gonna find the Boar Man
Boar Man?
Boar man?
(metal creaking) Boar man?
boar man?
Ah uhhhh
Okay all right, okay?
(distant rock 'n' roll instrumental)
Okay
Thunk, thank thunk
useless junk, coffee?
That's hardly useless junk
for my experience coffee fixes all my problems
Nice, nice, nice, nice. Okay
Boar man? Hello.
Whelp, got that, that's a thing I just got
*game thunking*
Useless junk
Thunkity thunkity. Gotta hide from this boar man!
Hope I don't make---ooo---Hope I don't make too much noise!
Thunka, thunka-lunk
Alright
squeaky squonky ooh, that's not good
(rattle of car engine)
ahh... OHHH!
BOARMAN
That is a boar man.
(Boar man speaking)
(OnO)
ah
OH
Oh no
I've been through this before
oh boar man
ah
No
God, it's oulast before outlast happened
Eugh
I don't wanna be that lion
Returns it---Oh boy
Oh boy-eehahh
Okay. Well, alright. you got shoes. Ah! Uh..
Screwdriver! Yeah, screw---uhhh
Screwdriver, okay.
Alright. Got that.
Oo, get that.
Oookay, alright. this not going nowhere
Alright,  how about oh, yeah, this on it?
Yeah. Scr--really squonk it.
You gotta really-- I said you got a REALLY squonk it
(really squonking it)
Eugh, come oooonn!
Oh come on!
Oh boy, there we go
Got a key, Key, key. All the keys
(keys jingling) Ah
(door opens) Okay, I'm outtie
Nowhere
Jesus, this really is... God. It's a secret passage. Is it? Really?
Whoa
Okay, nice key. What did you do to this key? All right. Well, anyway, all right fluug
See ya
This game really is like a precursor its..
this game came out like 2014
like before any of this stuff that I'm like getting deja vu from. Which is super weird
All right, okay, anyway.
See ya. See ya boy-man. See ya Ugly..
That is your ugly. *chuckle* Ugly! Oh, that's his house. Okay? Now. I know where he lives in case I need to come back
Okay, all right. where am I?
Ugh THUNK! ha
Gotta hide
Thunka-lunka-lunkal
Maybe I could flush it, yeah.
Oh?
Well, That's a problem. Oh, here the solution? Where am I now? What is going on? Okay
Gotta bucket! Hey guys I got a buucket!
Anybody wanna see my bucket?
Can I fill it up here? Is this where I could fill it?
Okay, so this is ---- WAHH
(loud thudding)
(growl)
HOkay.. Alright.
see ya dood...
See ya. Could flush the drain with some water, okay awuu
Whoopi whoop-- oh, man. I'm total. I'm getting lost to where I am
Okay, well that's a thing now
Anything in the trash cans?  ooh
Only open from the other side you say? Okay, well I try-
OOOH
Okay, alright. Well, that's a way out...
I think-- or at least a way around
so I gotta
Do something to fix all this bullshit. Hey, can you donate some fluids?
Could you donate some fluids please?
Some sweet fluids? All right. Anyway. See ya
friend
Ai yai yai yai ... so, I'm thinking it has something to do with this
I mean there's obviously like a leak there, so
Oo --Wait, no, I know I can get back
and then, uh,
if I go back I can, uh, there's water elsewhere-- whoa
Hmm there's water elsewhere right?
Wouldn't there be--ooh
uhhhhhhhhh...
Can I get some water, maybe the kitchen one----ohhh the bathroom, that's right
oohh
Here yeah... Okay!
I have to go a long way back, but I got that!
Good thing I remembered. Geezums..
Alright, heh, excuse me Boar man, Sorry for being away for so long.
I do apologize greatly
thunkle..
Okay, the object must be downstairs
Probably..?
Okay, I think it's-- I think there was a drain over by... Mr. Ugly. Oh, yeah
Oh, weak hair pin, could be used as a lockpick
Greeeeaaat
All that trouble for a---how did I know?
How could I tell?
In what universe did that make sense? all right whatever? Let's pick this lock?
Alright, whatever..
Let's uh... pick this lock?
Well, that didn't work. Okay
(Mark mumbling)
*gasp* Wait! No, the gate, yeah.  THE GATE!
Aaauggh
I got it! Okay. I'm on the right track. I'm --Ooo a scooty doo? There's some fuel left in it.. Okay, alright.
Okay. All right. Well apparently. I got nothing to-- graveyard! Even better. There's some fuel left in that graveyard
Ugh
Doesn't seem to be dug a long time ago
At least they had the common courtesy to bury 'em, after they murdered them horri--
Oh, devil is here?  No, don't like that
Again! Heh,
Not good omens. You're spelling out for me
useless junk? Devil in---
aaHAAAeeyyy
(flies buzzing)
Nnnuggh
Thank you. Thank you for that. Thank you.
Nothing but human remains.. Great, great, wonderful, eh, grunderful.
Okay.. Oh!
(strange groaning)
Noo, I'm gonna go with no. How about no is my response. Is that an-- *scoffs* Is that adequate?
Nothing but human remains. Nothing but humAN r'mains.
OO a key!
That was awfully-- That was worth all the emotional scarring, I believe from that.
venture
Alright, anyway.
Not gonna take the flowers, I guess. Alright, see ya!
Everybody! See ya. I got a key, another key..
A key? *chuckles* No? Okay.
All right. Imma- I'm an idiot. Okay, alright. I''m foolish.
Wait! Did I go? Yeah, no bore man safe?
Hey--
Okay, alright, okay. Well, that's weird. Why are you there? No Boar man?--the password is no boar man!
NAMROBONE
EFA-SAFE -- I don't know okay, all right. I'll be back. I know...
Where would this key be to? There was, uh, there was that other door that I tried to pick..
Let's see, locked tight..
Ahaa!
Okay, all right. Fish! Love it!
Love it!
Oh, oh, oh fish. Less love it. I don't love it as much
I love it not!
Uh, don't do that, please. Eh, stop everything you're doing is horrible.
Why is there a human leg in there?
Why is anything, anything in this entire place?
Okay, you know what? I should leave.
That's what I should do. I don't know why I was hanging around to be perfectly honest.
Ah, nice and refreshing
Ah
Well that's not what I wanted!
okay, so I'm going back around ..
Good god, what is going on here?
(Boar man has returned! OnO)
Well
Alrighty then
Can I blounk him with a shovel?
Alright, Se-see ya Boar man!
See ya dood!
See ya!
Sayonara!
Oo!
Hello, Mr. Cat nibbles. I expect you to take care of the mouse plague in my kitchen.
Please hurry up. My restaurant opens in two days.
*chuckles* Kind reguards, Mr. Cottonfish
What kind of weird world do we live in?
What does it mean?
What does it -mmmb
Hi?
*quietly* oh god..
No!
How about no!
How about I bloank you with this?
Ya know--
Just..oh god..
mMMm
Again, I just want to say no and then walk away from the situation
because that's the only logical conclusion when you're approached with that
conundrum
No! *chuckles* No. No, I won't do it. I refuse!
Okay. Let's see what's up the lighthouse.
Ah..
Saw something out of the corner of my eye
Sorry, I'm a little spooked. Light reveals, need battery.
That's- Okay. That's
That's what I need. Alright, that's what I need apparently.
Okay. Alright then. Well, I'm go get you a snack
Something that's not fish-- How about a nice boar?
I bet you'd like thaaaat. Okay
No fish, huh? No fish? Alright. Human leg? Would you like humAN leg?
I got a nice human leg
Hmm
Oooh
Seems to be a mouse living in there. Ho oh!
Wehell I know how to fix a mouse problem
Huhah.. So I need something to attract the mouse
But I --what do I have?
I don't have anything. There's no real food here..
Ugghf
It's just this human leg
Ugh
I don't know
So, I need something to be able to get that mouse out of there, but I'm not a hundred percent sure what.
Like, Have I seen anything? Have I seen, like some cheese?
No, no, no. What gets a mouse out?  I guess.
Ooohh! Come on! You boarded that bullshit up. Oh you asshole!
Frickin bag of ass, would you like a nice..
I don't have a flashlight in here anymore. Apparently I forgot.
I guess no. Okay?
That's weird. So have things changed here?
Has anything else changed?
Ugh
God. ....I don't know.
No?... Nothing.
OOOH
MooooH Mm Mm Mm
There's a mouse trap right there!  Ohhh, Ohhh.
Ahh
I was wandering around for like, forever.
Oohhh
Got it. Okay. Ahh! Well that was instantaneous results. Okay! Alright. See ya!
I'm off. I'm off to the races. Give me a battery, please.
You gonna eat that or?
You go--
You're just gonna look at it. All right. I'll see ya.
He just likes to eat in privacy, I guess. Alright. Okay. All right.
Well, I got a battery.
Thunk!
Huh.
Ahh!
Alright.
Okay
Wat dat doo?
What did it do?
Alright. What is it shining on right now, is the question. Right? ..something outside?
It would be shining upon. Something through here?
Something over here? Here?
In the graveyard?
Hello?
No? There's a lot more light right now
but why?
So that light has to do something. There's something very specific with the light.
Right?
There was another area that was dark, wasn't there?
Wait.
Wasn't there? It's gotta be something like back.
Right?
It would have to be
I would think so...
Uhh, don't like that. Well the lights shining here too. So maybe there's ..
Maybe there's something to this, Right?
Wait, the hallway.
No! But here. Close. Right? Something around here
Something here. I'm getting closer to the truth. Maybe it really was..
Maybe it really was down here. Nah, too dark. Okay, but!
It might be something more
There's a lot of light here right now. I'm not crazy crazy
De--OOOOHHh
What the hell Is that!?
What kind of bullshit is that? Deadmau5. Oh, Okay, alright. You talking about the musician?
Is that what you're talking about? Is that a password?
Alright. Okay. Alright.
Eh de--deadmau5!
A dead mouse!
Da-Dead mouse? Dead mouse. Is it dead mouse? Is it? I think it's dead mouse.
Dadmause
I don't know what that means. What the hell does that mean?
Did I actually have to click on it or something?
Whoops.
Oh! Tiff-t- I have to---Dauh
I had to click on it! Auwahh I did. I did.
I did. Awauaahahah
Ffine! Ffffine! Fine, fine, fine!
Yaaaay!
Friend! Hi friend.
(Don't make any trouble, pal.)
...... Okay. All right you- you-you-you you too! You too, buddy.
Hii.
*mockingly* MMMate!
Okay! all right!
Right, mate, I'm going downstairs..
I can't reach that
How about we use the Shovel? No, screwdriver?
Alright, fine.
Oh Hello.
Maybe I'm just smarter than you.
Maybe I didn't get caught by the boar man.
Maybe I was just a little quicker on the draw. Do you know what I'm saying?
Oh! Hi.
Mmm!
Okay. All right, so what are you guys doing down here anyway?
You just chilling? Hanging out. How do you get food?
Oh hi
You know I thought you were gonna be cool
You had a nice character design
But then you came out with a pun. Not only that but you came out screaming with a pun
It wasn't just a normal pun. You were screaming it.
Alright fine then. Oh it's a maze, is it?
God damn, This game is long, actually.  I didn't even re---oh hi
Which one? You're standing next to two!
*fustrated sigh*
This one? No, okay, *chuckles* not that one. I guessed and I was wrong
Oh, no wait, I was right... ahh
I see how we do here!
Ahh!
Got it! Nailed it! What did that do?
What did I do? Ah! Oh, Okay!
Beware! Outside!
(Waves crashing)
All right! Mheh.
Okay
Well deadmau5. Oh, I get it
All right.
it's not smart to let the boar man notice me. Okay.
No. That's the senpai I don't want on my back
Okay, fine, then. That's a little crooked
All right, what else we have here?
How about to the right?
Hello!
Ha ha!
No, I do not, thank you very much.
Why?
Why are they on the house? That doesn't--oooOOoOo!
That's a strong drink!
That's a strong drink
Okay, alright. Well, I got that then. That's nice. Free drinks
Hey! How's it going?
Goat Guy: I've been here for ten years now, still can't escape this shitehole
(in disbelief) Ten years? Ten years!
Ten years, are you kidding me?
What the hell.
Nah, I don't wanna. I'm trying to solve a puzzle here, don't 'cha know?
And can't you take those things off of your head? I gue-I guess not with the Boar man being all..
Serious about this stuff. How do they live here?
How does this? How does this work?
How does society carry on?
Okay. Damn it! Pfft I didn't mean to drink that
No, I'm not. Hang on, wait, hang on, I gotta go get another beer.
Let's see..
Thank you.
What if I?
What would I do with this?
I can't exactly like.. use it 'cause I just, don't click on stuff.
I'd have to click on it
Right? Ahh!
There was a back area. Ah okay alright.
Ooh hello
Heh- Hi
How are you doing?
Wha? Huh? Me?
Okay!
I know where to get that! I do, I swear. I know how to get it.
I know how to do that. Why won't you get some is the question. Ah nice thii--
*loud bang* Heyyyyy, what was that?
Well alrighty, then. I got some pills. Alright. Uhh..
Knock the people that I---Ey! I see you!
I got a shovel!
I'll shovel you good!
Alright, fine then, see ya.
Well, that walrus is dead. A heh! That's a dread walrus! Okay.
I gotta go get the gas can and then I got a knock everybody out in the sleeping room
I know how this works. I know what's going on here.
Hey, trust you me. I know exactly...
Thanks! Alright, I know exactly what's going on here.
La da da da da dee
Okay, got the jerrycan.
Lemme go ah..
to the room back here~
Alright, you want these?
You want these?
Nope.
Ohhh! I know what to doo!
Ah, Now that's a strong drink, so now
(Mark fake chuckling)
Put it. Put it down. Put it d--there we go.
Okay, I know what to do now,
Now that I got the Jerrycan
I knock out a Mr. Boar man
and that get the fuel and
get out of here
Which just means that I'm gonna die, because
the cap man is .. probably taking care of the other guy
Yeah, all right, so go here. Go here.
Go through here
through here
Doodly dedee~ Just gonna leave this.
Want that? You want that?
Sir?
Siiir
OOOOOooooooooahhwwwa ow
I puh
See my instinct was right, but my execution was flawed.
I know what I d---need to do.
There was only one of 'em that needed to be put to sleep
in that other one because one of them was already sleeeeeping
I get it. I get it. I'm a smart cookie
Here you go. Oh. No?
Okay. Well I guess.Alright, maybe that comes later because-- god damn it
I keep thinking I'm right then I'm wrong, but anyway, I got the gas so
Let's just go for it. I guess
I got the gaass!
Ah.
Oooohhh
See? My instinct was right
Execution
flawwwed
Just slightly flawed!
See I know what I'm on about. I know what I'm on about
Alright, aheeeehhh Go to sleep!
Ah, Sleeping like a baby goat.
Alright. Why did you steal that key dammit
uh oh... Gimmah Keeyas Gaaah
Let him sleep dammit. I'm trying. I'm trying to get out of here man.
Alright here we go.
Now, I bet walrus guy is now very dead
It's just an instinct
(BOAR MAN Jumpscare)  HEEEY!
Oooohh
Nope! I'm gonna go with no.
Hey gorilla, man. You might want to run.
Oh, He is already outie. Okay.
Well, that's not good.
YYYYyeeeee
OOOOhhhhh
Nooo! Nooo!
I dooon't knoooww.
Uh oh.
Well, I am boned.
Okay, I can't turn these off. Well, alright.
Heh.
Ha ha.
He halright.
WONK
Eah
Screwdriver!
Key!
You want some booze?
I don't know what to give ya
Well,
Ain't this a conundrum
It's as conundrumus as they come.
uh-huh
Okay, all right.
Ah! There we go!
Hey!
Happy birthday, okay. Got that. Got tha-ooohhh dead mouse..
Well, those assholes are gonna--- whoops! well.
Sorry. eeh aa
Ah, I got the key!
I know right?
Okay!
Did it work?
Are we free forever?
That was a terrible vacation,
Ah hehe heh
It's not over, is it?
(Sudden dramatic thun)
(Screaming) (Squelching)
(Monster breathing)
Why? Ooooooohhh...
(waves crashing)
Uhh oh
(Flies buzzing)
Well, that was fast!
Where'd those flies come from?
(Same string music as before)
(breaking Static) Oooheey I don't like th-ha-ha-hat
(loud static)
Hokay!
Alright.
(Music still playing)
Am I free now? (loud static) OOhhh
Mr. Whiskers: You can never win the game
(Mr. Whiskers laughing menacingly)
(Laugh overlapping itself)
(Laugh becoming demonic) ((Who let Darkiplier in here?))
(Mark imitating laugh)
(Mark chuckles while credits music begins)
What a silly Billy
Anyway, that was really, really good.
I loved that a lot and honestly all of the solutions wer---
I was thinking about things too in-deph. The solutions were always nearby where the problem was first arisen
So that was awesome. Let me know what you think down the comments below.
Thank you everybody so much for watching
I'll put a link to this game down in the description and like I said, it was made a long time ago, so honestly
It's really interesting to see how this kind of like skirted over everything. I've never- I've never even heard of this. So, anyway.
Thank you again. And as always, I will see YOU in the next video!
Bye- bye!
(Outro music ^u^)
(Watch out for Boar man, my friends!